on every measure from the economy
inflation borders energy National
Security he's missing in action let's
talk about them in order wait but I want
to challenge the premise Kennedy wants
to list them but he doesn't want to go
through one by one typical the economy
13.1 million jobs he's created more
these opposed Cova jobs you know that
well I mean that's an artificial number
no no then let me just let me see like
this as an as an opportunity to engage
civilly on this okay Fair Point your
president Donald Trump lost 2.6 million
jobs during his four years we've created
13.1 million fine you can maintain a
coveted frame how about the fact that
Joe Biden's created more jobs six times
more jobs than the previous three
Republican presidents are you going to
tell me that the average family where we
have two-thirds of Americans now living
paycheck to paycheck it was 70 under
Trump this is how you don't back down
from these bullies